usa el método de sustitución para
resolver este sistema de ecuaciones y
encontrar x y james 2 ya igual a x + 7 x
igual a menos 4 y bueno el método de
sustitución esencialmente lo que dice es
que tenemos que encontrar a una de estas
dos variables como función de la otra
para sustituir la en la otra ecuación y
así obtengamos una ecuación con
solamente una incógnita pero déjame
mejor escribir aquí las ecuaciones para
que entiendas mejor a qué me refiero 2
es igual a x + 7 y por otra parte tengo
que x es igual a jay menos 4 y bueno
como lo que estoy buscando es una x
nadie que cumpla
ambas ecuaciones ambas construcciones
estas dos las tiene que cumplir esta
solución que estoy buscando y por lo
tanto tiene que cumplir la ecuación de
abajo que dice que x es igual a menos 4
de la construcción de abajo tengo que la
x tiene que ser igual al menos 4 por lo
tanto qué te parece si sustituimos lo
que tiene que valer x según la segunda
ecuación en la 1ª ecuación para así
obtener una ecuación que solamente
dependa de llama es decir en lugar de
poner a x
ecuación la voy a sustituir por el valor
de 4 porque yo sé que se tiene que
cumplir que x sea igual a 100 menos
cuatro justa esta es la información que
me está diciendo mi segunda ecuación y
por lo tanto vamos a enchufar a esta x
aquí adentro entonces me quedaría que
todo siempre es igual a equis pero x es
igual a menos 4 por lo tanto en lugar de
x voy a escribir ye menos 42 y es igual
a menos 4 más 7 y estella menos 4 no te
pierdas salió de equis lo único que hice
fue sustituir el valor de x de la
información que me da la segunda
ecuación y ahora si tengo que 2 james es
igual al tiene unos 47 esto está mucho
más fácil de resolver porque es una
ecuación con solamente una incógnita
vamos a resolverla me queda que 2 james
es igual al menos 47 esto es lo mismo
que james más 3
si ahora resto de ambos lados de la
ecuación me va a quedar que 2 james
menos esto es lo mismo que james y por
otra parte del lado derecho obtengo que
jay menos y se van y me queda solamente
el 3 por lo tanto ya sé que el valor de
cumple este sistema de ecuaciones es
igual a 3 ahora lo que voy a hacer es
utilizar la segunda ecuación para
encontrar el valor de x y para encontrar
el valor de x lo que voy a hacer es
sustituir el valor de james en esta
ecuación de morado que tengo aquí x es
igual a ye pero lleva de 3 a 3 menos 4 y
bueno 3 menos 42 mismo que menos 1 y ya
también tengo el valor para x es decir
que el valor de x igual a menos 1 y de
igual a 3 es la solución de este sistema
de ecuaciones e inclusive lo podemos
verificar en esta ecuación de que
arriban 2 por 13-6 es exactamente lo
mismo que menos 17 muy bien si checa
ahora lo que quiero hacer a continuación
hasta que acabe el vídeo es hacer el
mismo método de sustitución pero en
lugar de sustituir a x en mi segunda
ecuación yo lo que quiero encontrar es
una expresión equivalente para ayer para
sustituirla en el primer ecuación es
decir aplicar este mismo método de
sustitución pero en lugar de sustituir a
x sustituir a yen ahora date cuenta que
esta ecuación de abajo si yo sumo 4 de
ambos lados de la ecuación voy a obtener
que x + 4 es igual a jr x + 4 es igual a
gemma y esto
de la segunda ecuación estas dos
expresiones son exactamente lo mismo si
yo sumo cuatro de ambos lados de la
ecuación y bueno entonces ya tengo que x
+ 4 es igual a bien o de otra manera y
es igual a x + 4 ahora qué te parece si
sustituye el valor de james en la
primera ecuación es decir en lugar de
poner game voy a poner x + 4 cada vez
que yo veo un ayer en la primera
actuación y me queda 2 por james es
decir 2 por x + 4
esto tiene que ser igual a x 7 y yo lo
que quiero ver es si llegamos a la misma
respuesta y bueno que me quede aquí 2 x
x 2 x 2 x 4 8 esto es igual a x 7 2 x +
8 es igual a x + 7 y si yo quito x de
ambos lados de la ecuación voy a obtener
es más voy a quitar xy también voy a
quitar 8 de una vez voy a quitar x y 8
de ambos lados la ecuación estos dos se
cancelan y de este lado solamente me
queda x2 x x es lo mismo que x y de este
lado estos dos se cancelan y me queda
más 7 menos 8 lo cual es menos 1 x igual
a menos 1 y ahora utilizando esta
ecuación que tengo de morado voy a
encontrar el valor de james
que es igual a menos 14 lo cual es 3
perfecto llegue a la misma solución es
decir que si yo sustituyó el valor de x
o sustituyó el valor de james llegó a la
misma respuesta son dos formas distintas
de aplicar el mismo método